notre première boum balle est venu
inviter à danser moi j'étais trop timide
à guillaume mascotte qui va arriver sur
scène une mascotte et concernent la vie
de quelqu'un quelqu'un quelqu'un quelque
quelqu'un quelques unes ou non je coule
pour savoir qui est concerné par cette
mascotte
voici un premier indice déjà j'aimerais
qu'on fasse entrer la mascotte également
c'est pas qu'on sait pas et alors c'est
parti première à nice voilà regarder la
première ce que vous pensez que l'on
n'oublie jamais son premier flat
est ce que vous pensez qu'on n'oublie
jamais son premier flirt remercie
d'ailleurs josiane balasko d'avoir fait
magnéto dans x men mais chaque os des
écoles publiques ses bases et ses bonnes
m
la mascotte et sur scène merci à la
mascotte est venu d'ailleurs merci
beaucoup
est ce que quelqu'un pense qu'on a
retrouvé son premier club parce qu'on va
pas se mentir c'est ça on a retrouvé le
premier flirt de quelqu'un autour de
cette table basse avec celui qu'on avait
retrouvé pour moi là c'est un vrai gars
c'est un le voyez bien tout de suite
déjà ça peut pas être l'ex d'isabelle
tiennent debout aujourd'hui quoi neymar
y aujourd'hui
ouais bah écoute et apparemment il a
fait son chemin et apprécié apparemment
ce flirt lui a porté chance
ah ouais bien cherché on a deuxième
indice regarde et que notre coeur a fait
boum
lors de votre première boum au
est ce que votre coeur a fait boum boum
lors de votre première boum plus près il
énigmes du père fouras puis je trouver
une question est ce que tu peux pas
inquiéter ses heures qu'ils sont en
banane dans d'accord sur tout cas vous
connaissez bien des missions non mais il
est en panne les shearing est ce que
vous pensez que c'est vous c'est votre
ex et c'était là beaucoup d'anglais
c'est une preuve d'orgueil et culture
c'est qu'ils parlent pas anglais
ah oui est-ce que vous pensez que c'est
votre premier flirt non je pense pas
caroline je pense pas je me souviens de
son traîneau et isabelle je pense pas
bien que contre massaquoi famille et bd
boum le montant minimum d'accord à
l'issue d'un boom jeunesse iran et au
plus peut-on petit gilles
non je crois pas jean michel basset des
mains d'hommes dont je pense pas que ce
soit moi j'avais pu franchir moment là
je me souviens même moi c'est pas donné
mais non ça me dit rien
castaldi alors moi non je ne connais pas
ses mains sachez que la personne
s'appelle maximum maxime et serait donc
un homme oui maxime est ce que quelqu'un
commence à voir de quoi il s'agit
selinger
non mais en fait vous n'avez tout
tellement eu ces horribles que le
premier fils avait pas mal le premier
flirt si je vous dis maxima note
menottes maradona c'est pourri alors
c'est qu'il ya maxime marotte qui dit il
est trop chou et oui ça va être qui on
parle ou pas oui bah vous étiez très
bien ce qui bat c c'est un ami d'enfance
non
[Applaudissements]
ça plaît tu n'as les enfants ça a poussé
par un ami d'enfance
non mais c'est l'humain dans la banane
je sais pas ouais on dirait j'ai dit que
c'était maxime manager panique s'était
qu'est ce que vous en savez les petits
max et kimmo timmonen basse et c'est
vrai c'est vous parler de boom on a fait
nos premières boums ensemble on a vu
qu'elle arborait vous êtes se moquer on
a kiffé life quoi je vais danser sur du
céline dion ah oui oui oui
ah ouais on était en cinquième il paraît
que vous étiez une bonne élève a donc
deuxième adista dernière année d'études
j'adore écouter maxime de venir me
rejoindre d'abord aux mascottes
[Applaudissements]
là
[Musique]
on arrive on a tous en mémoire la tête
du premier flirt de qena la musique
combien ça va mal c'est lui qui chante
ainsi faire parce que maxime il est
chanteur il a un album en préparation
maxi minéraux maxime déjà je voulais
dire merci d'être là tard d'amour années
de rien et 50 alors maxime avant qu'on
voit dans découvre son visage que
c'était le premier flirt de kelly vous
étiez dans la même classe en sixième
ouais c'est ça oui vous êtes restés dans
le même établissement scolaire jusqu'à
la seconde
oui oui tout à fait j'aime bien maxime
je trouve sympathique
by louis maxime le premier slow c'est
elle qui vous invite à danser
et ouais ouais enfin comment ça s'est
passé nativement on était chez claire à
côté de moi c'est clair c'est notre
première bouille
oui eh ben elle est venue invite à
danser moi j'étais trop timide huawei et
ça se voit donc la vie moins timide
maintenant ouais sapin ça va tranquille
travail alors qu'il y paraît que c'est
une bonne élève
ouais et tu nous a ramené des photos
parce que kelly à l'époque ce n'est pas
du tout facile d'échanger la même eu les
cheveux rouges en troisième est-ce que
vous avez des photos de kelly b novelli
de l'époque s'il vous plaît chez agatha
voilà regardez ces photos ce n'est pas
vous tourner à d'autres photos de kelly
c'était vraiment la d'eau dans leurs
rangs
maxime et regarde et elisabeth d'accueil
on dirait benhalima rien à voir c'est
vrai et c'est chaud là dedans
pourquoi oui au regard des pièges et
bout mais c'est vrai que ces photos est
basse et kelly c'est bon c'est pas grave
c'est moi mais c'est max oui ces photos
abbas arrivé
ouais c'est ma faute et c'est le plus
fort j'avais jamais des photos maxime
est ce que vous vous êtes galocher kelly
et toi c'est vraiment oui moi jamais ah
non jamais j'exerce max c'est pas vrai
justin smoak justin dans ma famille
j'étais quand ça pour troisième en
troisième et il n'y a même pas une
petite cloche même pas comme gilles et
pera on nie pas les faits alors qu'eddy
on va revoir
maxime puisque vous allez découvrir
maxime ah oui maxime merci en tout cas
être là aurait les deux jours d'être est
en fait une erreur et doit toujours
regarder voix le regard des matchs
[Applaudissements]
merci max
cameron
[Applaudissements]
j'aimerais que vous repartiez le sio de
ce lourd ah oui tous les deux bah oui
c'était la vague dans sa mais vas-y mon
chéri mettez-vous là
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je veux le faire
vous n'êtes pas vu depuis longtemps
ah merde oui et alors et est ce que vous
pourriez reprendre tous les deux ah ben
moi aujourd'hui je suis marine non merde
j'avais existants les cascades d'eau
s'il était marié 1
aujourd'hui kelly moi c'est comme ma
cousine quoi c'est vrai et bon thé des
soeurs comme ça le bac il est trop miné
ouais mais microturbo gaza n'empêche il
et j'aime bien j'aime bien et ça c'est
un bon chanteur et chez trop faire un
album moi je suis fier je suis fière
d'elle de cette aide vient elle est
géniale et un album qui va sortir
ouais c'est ça tu verras nous ferons là
ils vous parlent pas mais avec la gare
en plaisir est un amour d'avoir été
alors
non merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]